let's just bring you the latest pictures
that we have of the new king he is
meeting staff and academics from the
University of cambridge's Whittle
Laboratory
um including leaders from the aviation
industry and Senior government
Representatives as well uh Grant chefs
is down there as is George Freeman as
well Secretary of State of the
department for energy security and Net
Zero and minister of State for science
Innovation and Technology he is a patron
of Cambridge University's Institute for
sustainability leadership which is part
of this laboratory and they hope that
this laboratory will become the leading
Global Center for disruptive innovation
as they call it in Net Zero Aviation and
energy and will help bring together
Global experts in research and
industries he's doing all the
handshaking that he normally has to do
before he goes and tours the actual
laboratory itself inside here the
facilities include is going to see
demonstration of key Technologies and
methods that will be enabled by the new
lab and the main aim of this laboratory
apparently is to halve the time it takes
to develop key Technologies towards net
zero Aviation and energy